good evening members
good evening everybody and welcome to
this virtual meeting of the council
before we commence the meeting i would
like to ask those present
to join with me in a minute silence
to mark the anniversary of the first
lockdown
we can reflect on how life has changed
during this year
and remember the people who have lost
their lives during the coronavirus
pandemic
and their families who mourn them we
should also remember that many people
lost
loved ones during this period due to
reasons other than covid
and that their families were also unable
to visit them in hospital
and attend funerals we may also
wish to think of people who have lost
their jobs or suffered in other ways
and we may just want to pause at this
time
to re-evaluate as to what we now
consider
important let us hope for
and look forward to a better future
especially following the rollout of the
vaccination programme
to which so many have contributed please
join me in a minute silent
silence to reflect on this
thank you
now to the meeting may i first of all
remind you of some domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones are muted
and cameras switched off when you are
not speaking
that you do not interrupt other speakers
members are reminded not to use the
messaging
chat function during the meeting unless
it is to report a pecuniary
or non-pecuniary interest or to notify
the chair
that you wish to make a proposal that if
you are attending the meeting
to speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting
you may be asked to leave additionally
you'll be invited to speak and ask
questions by the chair
please await your turn
if members lose connection to the
meeting
please contact the member support
officer mandy smith
as soon as possible as this is a virtual
meeting
you will not need to stand to address
the chair
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting
will be broadcast live to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential
or exempt items if you make a
representation to the meeting
you'll be deemed by the council to have
consented to being filmed
by entering this meeting you are also
consenting
to being filmed by the council and to
the possible use of those images
and sound recordings for webcasting
and or training
the council members of the public
and the press may record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded
can i move to the agenda now please
apologize for absence
thank you chair i have received
apologies for absence from councillor
barrett and councillor norman
thank you declaration
of interest by councillors are there any
declarations of interest
thank you item three
bc 2027
to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on 23rd february
2021 for accuracy only
are there any issues with accuracy
councilor osborne did you want to um
comment on the minutes
you're you're on mute counselor osborne
you're on mute
no i'm sorry uh madam chairman i was um
going to propose the uh
propose the minutes okay i'll just um
check that there are no other
comments fine yes thank you councillor
osborne
that's no problem can i have a seconder
please
so i'll second that madam chairman
councillor peterville
thank you councillor beer so um
we have account a proposal and secondary
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office
to conduct the electronic vote thank you
chair
councillors the vote is now opening in
modern.gov please can you go to the
cross
and mark your vote thank you
councillor beer councillor mayberry
councillor plum and councillor lindsay
we're still awaiting your vote
are you able to do so would you like me
to take your vote verbally
um could you hear me verbally please
can't it's robert lindsay here
yeah can can i have your vote please yes
yes agreed okay thank you
councillor plum agreed i thought i had
voted
okay councillor mabry
answer maybe are you able to cost your
vote or would you like to do it verbally
okay chair we'll we'll go without cancer
maybe at the moment i think she might be
having technical problems
thank you
thank you that was a unanimous vote so
the meet
the minutes of the meeting have been
confirmed and will be signed at the next
practicable
opportunity item four
announcements from the chairman and
leader
i refer you to paper bc 2028 for noting
um and in fact one of the um
meetings didn't take place um so
um that's not absolutely accurate
but um apart from that uh that's all i
have to say on that for now
council award do you have anything to
report
yeah uh thank you madam chairman uh yes
i did just start
bringing that up on the screen
today members on this national day of
reflection earlier we stood united in
remembering those who've lost their
lives as a result of covid
our thoughts are with those who have
lost loved ones and seen their lives
impacted in ways
they could not have imagined a year ago
we paid tribute to our teams
our public sector colleagues and the
army of volunteers who have kept
essential services running
and supported our communities in the
face of unprecedented challenges
the rollout of the vaccine and
availability of community testing brings
hope for the year ahead
if we continue to follow the guidelines
in the meantime we will continue to
support the recovery of our towns and
businesses
so that baba continues to be somewhere
people are proud to call home
post covert and beyond
now the latest data actually shows a
continuing decline again in the
infection rate to levels not since
uh seen since last summer and here in
baber it is now down to 19.6 per hundred
thousand
the lowest in the county and a long way
from the nearly 640 per hundred thousand
we had in early january
we are however seeing a slight rise in
parts of the county following the
reopening of schools
and a significant increase in testing
there is further good news and that the
death rate is now not above the seasonal
average
the vaccination rollout in suffolk is
still going very well
one of the best in england and in baby
almost everyone over 50 has now had
their first vaccination
many have now had both doses and this
will be the focus of the vaccination
program next month
let's hope any short-term reduction in
supply won't delay the removal of
lockdown restrictions
and we can have a good summer
you will have seen that baber and mid
suffolk have been shortlisted in three
categories of
this year's iez public sector
transformation awards including council
of the year
this is really exciting news and a
testament to the innovation that is
at the heart of everything we do and
also to the excellence of our staff
it is a welcome counterweight to the
disinformation peddled about us on
social media
please watch the videos they are very
good
and now i want to address the continuing
ranker over the future of the bellevue
site in sudbury
i know that the chosen way forward is
not liked by some but it is gratifying
that this
is balanced by others who understand
that something needs to be done
and that a pragmatic solution has been
found that stands a chance of being
implemented
there is a myth that we didn't consider
all six bids or didn't give them equal
consideration
this is nonsense in addition to bid
price all were assessed equally and
fairly against the same qualitative
criteria which were listed in the public
paper all bidders were contacted during
the process
none was ignored and those who had not
included sufficient information by the
end date were given a further two weeks
to provide more
the selected bids scored significantly
higher overall than the others
meeting the section 123 criterion to
spoke to dispose of land
for the best consideration that can
reasonably be obtained
the overview and scrutiny committee
decided overwhelmingly yesterday that we
had conducted the cabinet
debate in a proper manner and that our
decision was therefore
sound following the demise of the hotel
bid we took on board the strong desire
to see a new entrance to the park from
the town
and developed a compromise solution that
will be funded from the sale
and has the huge advantage in that it
can be delivered it is a pity that
others aren't prepared to compromise as
well and support a solution that will
finally see the regeneration of this
gateway to the town
and deliver a part that the whole town
can be proud of
while on the subject of sudbury i just
want to remind members that we have
already put a huge amount of investment
into the town
and that we are proposing much more with
our vision for prosperity
this investment either direct from baber
or from the grants we have been able to
secure now amounts over four million
pounds in the past few years
so contrary to another myth that we
neglect the town and don't spend
anything there
we do and we'll continue to do so it is
our principal town
the engine of our economy and we are
determined that
it will be transformed to be fit for the
coming decades
a town for the 2050s not the 1950s
unfortunately this investment isn't
appreciated by all
and to paraphrase a well-known film it
does seem to be a case of
but apart from the leisure center
upgrade the financial support for
cultural venues
the environmental improvements including
solar carports cctv
newcastle housing additional temporary
accommodation the virtual high street
the vision master
plan and investment in park facilities
what has baba ever done for us
unfortunately for those who remember the
scene in the film we can't claim the
last item mentioned
the romans may have brought peace but it
seems we're still somewhere off that in
sudbury
thank you madam chairman thank you
council award
item five to receive notification of
petitions
in accordance with council procedure
rules non-received
chair thank you item six
questions by the public in accordance
with council procedure rules
i refer you to the question in the
tabled papers
i would like to invite mr morelli to ask
his question
mr morelli are you there yes thank you
um so my question is to councillor holt
in the cabinet's recent decision of the
sale of the land at bellevue
and during the cabinet debate on the
item why was seemingly little or no
notice taken
and little or no regard had to sudbury
town council's views on the future of
bellevue as outlined in the report of
the bellevue working party
and why was this report and the town
council's views seemingly dismissed by
yourself as being quote
late in the day without a true
consideration of the merits on which the
report was based
thank you mr morelli i would now like to
invite councillor holt
to respond thank you chair uh thank you
mr moretti for your question
it is very tempting to be drawn into
answering your question by giving a
detailed account
of cabinet's decision making at its
last meeting as you will appreciate
however
that has already been carried out by our
overview and scrutiny committee
following the calling of the cabinet's
decision and
also by sudbury town council at
its extraordinary meeting last week
is also tempting as i would
allow me as it would allow me to correct
several of the inaccuracies
or assumptions that were presented at
the town council meeting
i will resist the temptation though as i
really
do not think is helpful or healthy
for the district or town council to get
into
the habit of critiquing each other's
meetings
what is more important is that we
respect one another
one another's differences of views where
they exist
and work together for the residents of
sudbury
that we both represent
with that in mind you are correct that i
observed that the town council's formal
stance
was received not long before the cabinet
met
the town council's views were
and are however clear and
easily understood and so formed a proper
part
of cabinet's collective considerations
in reaching its decision thank you
thank you councillor holt mr morelli
would you like to ask a supplementary
question
you're on mute
thank you and i apologize and with your
permission chair i would like to ask the
following
supplementary question could i ask
councillor holt
what steps he is taking to ensure that
the views of sudbury town council are
taken into account
when as a key factor when baba are
making decisions that affect the town
including those related to bellevue
especially as
judging by the town council's public
meetings they do not currently seem to
feel
that their views are being considered by
baber very much if at all
council could you would you like to
reply
yes i pick up on mr moretti's comments
and i would say that currently we are
undergoing some meetings with sudbury
town council
we've met with the clerk and one other
council member recently twice
to discuss not only bellevue but other
projects and
opportunities coming forward for sudbury
i understand as i say that
you you have concerns and i think
sudbury town council and their residents
have concerns that possibly
we aren't getting as i said as well as
as perhaps we should be
but from my point of view and i
appreciate the cabinet has also
has this view as well that we will work
tirelessly to ensure that
that relationship improves and that for
the good
of sudbury and the local community we
will work
very very hard to ensure that we are
more attuned
and have more dialogue and open
conversation
so that in future hopefully the town
council
and the district council will present
themselves in a much better way
to the public
thank you councillor holt uh
thank you and this is the end of this
public question
section
item seven questions by councillors
in accordance with council procedure
rules non-received chair
thank you item 8 bc
2029 overview and scrutiny committee
report
i would like to invite council mccraw to
introduce paper bc
2029 which is for noting
council macro thank you very much chair
um i'm pleased to introduce the report
bc
2029 you find on pages 29
to 36 of today's papers
they cover meetings held by overview and
scrutiny
on the 18th of january uh the subjects
there being the town center parking and
the budget
the 15th of february where we discussed
citizens advice
and once again on the 15th of february a
review of a petition validation
the report is a little lengthier than i
would normally make it
due to the high degree of public
interest in many of these matters
i think it speaks for itself i've
endeavoured to make it as complete as
possible
and i'm happy to take any questions now
or after the meeting
thank you council macro are there any
questions for councillor mccraw
councillor mayberry
uh thank you thank you chairman um
i it's not a question it is a comment
because
uh councillor mccror has mentioned the
citizens advice i declare that i am a
director
of the citizens advice in in sudbury
um i also wish to apologize that i had
temporarily
lost contact but i am back
now so my apologies thank you
are there any questions any further
questions for council macro
thank you well in that case if there are
no
further questions or no questions um
we'll move on
and um thank you council mccraw that
report was for noting
we'll move on to item nine
bc 2030
community infrastructure levy sill
expenditure framework third review march
2021
i would like to invite councillor arthy
to introduce paper bc
2030 and to move the recommendations in
the report
counselor arthi thank you chairman
um yeah firstly just a little bit of
background
um as i'm sure you're all aware the sill
expenditure framework was originally
agreed and adopted
by both baber and mid-suffolk in march
2018
it has been reviewed twice through the
work of the joint member panel
and has also been to joint overview and
scrutiny on both occasions
the first and second reviews led to
changes being
made to the framework and the
communication strategy
in march 2019 and april 2020
it was agreed in april 2020 that the
sill expenditure framework would be
reviewed again
in october 2020 with any changes being
put in place before the next bid round
that's big round number seven
which opens on the first of may
also that the joint member panel would
inform the third seal expenditure
framework
review process the third review has
taken place
with the joint member panel you see
paragraph 1.3 of your report
and the council report and the changes
um to appendix a which is the sill
expenditure framework
and the comms strategy which said
appendix b
are the outcomes of the panel
and i bring this paper to you on their
behalf
there are some key changes and
they're set out in full in the report in
paragraph 4.5
the main change relates to
cross-boundary bids
so with development close to our
district boundaries
we anticipate demand for contributions
from neighbouring authorities
so there are new additional criteria for
dealing with such sealed bids
in simple terms they must be
collaborative
so baba will not contribute a hundred
percent
baber and mid suffolk's still spend must
be proportionate
to what's being provided and the most
important bit that we thought was that
it must be linked by
evidence to impact to the impact of
growth
within baba which must address the
evidence-based
impacts so in other words if there's a
proposal
we must have the evidence to support why
the bid is coming to us
and we must have the evidence of how the
the growth is being impacted
um to support that that bid they must be
specifically deliverable projects with
time scales for delivery
and they must have all of the necessary
formal approvals in place
also um that we should be the final part
of the funding jigsaw
so that still bids um sorry so that sell
funds
are not tied up in projects that aren't
going to be delivered
they must be capital-based specific
projects that address the growth impacts
we will not fund projects which are not
classed as infrastructure
the specific infrastructure projects
must be listed in the infrastructure
delivery plan
and within the infrastructure funding
statement
the same engagement process for paris
councils
and board members and for the county
councillors
as already set out in the framework
and all such sill expenditure beyond
each district
administrative and geographical
boundaries
shall be cabinet decisions that is no
matter
what the value of our contribution the
decision will be made by cabinet
not under delegated powers
all seal bids for expenditure beyond the
district's
boundaries must come from adjoining
local authorities and
infrastructure providers so in that
regard we will not expect
community bids from communities outside
of our district boundary
move to the sill expenditure framework
communication strategy which is at
appendix b
uh the key changes there are really
updates um they're intended
to try and get the sill message across
a little bit more successfully so
they provide some clear key messages on
a fact sheet
type fact sheet type basis to cover
different
aspects of seal for our website
they propose that we continue with
regular briefing sessions
for members and also parishes
and there's also an alteration of the
wording to reflect that parish briefings
will take place in a virtual setting
okay we need to continue
to improve communication um around seal
particularly for members and parishes
and the working group
identified that there is still a lack of
awareness
amongst some district councillors and
quite a lot of parishes
so the recommendations are at 3.1
that baber and mid-suffolk councils this
is obviously
um something that's got to be agreed by
both approved the amendments to the seal
expenditure framework
march 2021 which has arisen from the
third review that's appendix a
and the sill expenditure framework
communication strategy
march 2021 which is appendix b
three point two that baba a group baber
and mid suffolk agree that the sill
expenditure framework and the seal
expenditure framework communication
strategy
be reviewed again whilst bid round eight
is being considered that's in october
2021
so that any amended scheme can be in
place before bid round nine
occurs may 2022
so i think it's fairly clear here you
can see the annual review
um so we have the sale panel we have the
approval we have the ons scrutiny
and then we come around to the next year
and
finally at 3.3 that baber agrees the
joint
member panel be retained to inform
the fourth review so in other words we
retain this panel
for the next review starting in october
so that's 3.1 3.2 and 3.3 as per the
papers and i propose those
recommendations
thank you councillor can i have a
seconder please
i'm happy to second council award thank
you council award
so now we can move to questions
councillors may ask as many questions as
they wish
however they must be relevant to the
subject under discussion
and must be a question have you got any
questions
counselor maybe are you asking a
question
[Music]
yes i am thank you it wouldn't come off
off mute
um yes but uh thank you chairman my
question to
councillor arthi is um you you've
mentioned
cross-border sill bids could you
actually
confirm if there is a percentage
that is needed for cross border bids
whether it's
it has to be um 52
for example from baber and 48
from essex um or
is there such a thing please if you
could confirm that would be great
no there isn't it would depend on each
individual proposal
so in baby at the moment there have been
some inquiries
um but there are no um there are no bids
that we're considering at the moment so
this is preparing for the future
um one of the reasons to prepare for the
future is because
there has been in mid-suffolk um
a proposal for contributions
from developments in the thurston area
um to
some heads so the the logic behind all
of this
is that if there are fairly large
developments
um on the edge of our district um it is
quite possible
um that those people um
and we're collecting seal for that
development those people will be using
infrastructure outside of our district
um it does cut both ways um and it's
quite possible
um that there may be like for instance
households and recycling centre
used by people over the border you
mentioned essex so it is quite possible
that people might use sudbury facilities
but come outside of district so yes it
does cut the other way as well
at the moment there are no work sort of
fully worked up proposals
for baber to consider but this is in
preparation
so that we can deal with cross-boundary
issues in either in either direction
you've got to remember that some of the
other authorities are not
sill levying authorities um so they will
be looking to contribute to
infrastructure through section 106
agreements
um but if we're asked to contribute it
would be via sill
does that answer your question yes but
it prompts another question if i may
madam chairman
yes you may thank you thank you very
much
um would you not think it
would or that you the seal team or
any of these civil officers consider it
prudent to actually put some type of
percentage on across border
no not at all i mean the whole night i
did um try and cover that
um the the point is that what the panel
said um is that it must be
evidence-based
so if there's evidence that the
infrastructure that's over the border is
going to be used
75 percent by baba residents then
presumably
um the proposal will be for 75
it's highly likely that the evidence
will point towards
much lower usage cross boundary than
that
so it may well be 10
20 30 um
the there has been talk from ipswich
about transport
improvements in the town and
they so far have quoted a traffic survey
that they've done
that says that there's a proportion of
traffic that comes into ipswich every
day
to use its facilities and
they have a figure on that traffic
survey that they think should support
um any um proposal they might have for a
contribution from us
what we're saying on the panel is that
we want
proper full evidenced research that
actually
shows the level of um usage of
infrastructure across boundary
from any any development that might take
place and and here we're talking about
sprouting
thank you um thank you very much i will
keep my
further comments for the debate thank
you
thank you councillor mayberry councillor
hinton have you got a question
uh yes madam chairman thank you very
much um i've got some comments for the
debate as well
okay uh but i'll save those until we get
into the debate
uh councilman arthi uh you mentioned
that some of the
surrounding authorities do not have sil
regimes but use 106
monies for their infrastructure surely
that implies that any effect that
of any development on their
infrastructure is
tied down at the time of granting the
planning permission
and therefore contributions from our
silpot
would not be necessary um
that only applies if they can attach
that 106 to a development
so if you're talking about development
that goes cross-boundary
um yes there will be an element of that
development where section 106
contributions will be collected and
there'll be an element of that
development
where um cell contributions will be
collected by us
um but there are other situations um and
sprawtin is
is an example um there will be no 106
contributions
um from the land adjacent to sprawton
that might have been received by ipswich
because there's no development there
so we're talking about strategic
infrastructure here
so they would effectively be asking for
a contribution towards
a sort of an ipswich wide project
and they'd be asking for a contribution
from our seal
pot if you like
does that answer your question
councillor hinton
not really but i'll save any further
comments i have for the debate
okay thank you are there any further
questions
from councillors
oh councillor busby have you got a
question
we're just following up on that clive
what happens if the uh
the development in sprout and the uh if
you're referring to is also section 106
and not still
it it doesn't make any difference does
it because we we are now
uh still charging authority i get what
you're
what you're saying here because some of
the older sprawton um approvals are not
still generating it it wouldn't make any
difference i mean it's the provision of
infrastructure
so when the need arises when the need is
identified and it's fully evidenced
they may well ask for a contribution
from baber i
i don't think that any of these
proposals are going to be
huge the biggest one that's reared its
head
so far is the one that i mentioned um
about transport improvements
in ipswich and and it's it's kind of
early days on that
but i think you can understand that if
there
is a significant scheme um
with regard to transport improvements in
ipswich
it would only be expected i think that
ipswich would ask
um for a contribution from
neighbouring authorities what we're
saying is if they get to the stage of
asking for it
it must be fully evidenced so instead of
just coming in and saying right we think
we've got a 20 million pound scheme and
we think you'd like to pay a quarter
because you're one of the adjoining
authorities
we would turn around and say well you
know let's have some evidence of how
you've come up
with a quarter of 20 million pounds
because it should be based on the
required infrastructure so it's all to
do with um
requiring the evidence to support a
proposal
would we also have an opportunity to
contribute actually
to question the viability of the scheme
itself
they haven't got a particularly good
reputation for their traffic
changes what with uh one-way systems the
bridge that wasn't
traffic lights etc yeah it would
i hear what you're saying um it would
have to be
what what christine thurlow calls oven
ready
so it would have to be a scheme that is
fully worked up fully costed
um you know we would ahead of that we
would require the evidence but yes when
they when they get to the actual
proposal
um we would expect it to be ready to go
we would expect to be the final part of
the jigsaw to fund a project which would
then take place
okay thanks we're not going to just hand
them lots and lots of money and then
they're going to wander off
do some sort of uh i don't know
bridge project or something which never
happens and then say oh whoops we've
spent all of your money
that's not going to happen we would only
fund a deliverable project
um that had got all of its relevant
approvals i think i said that at the
start
um and and we would be kind of the final
part of the jigsaw so we would not be
the main
contributor to a scheme we would just be
making a contribution
great thank you councillor mayberry
another question i do and thank you
madam
chairman um just take my hand down
before i forget
uh thank you my um i note
and whilst i do not disapprove
that all seal bids should be discussed
first with a civil officer could
counselor arthi confirm
how much time this takes up from
a particular officer's work project
i mean are we talking 10 20 50
please thank you sorry just to follow up
on that
what ten percent of what their time
yes um because obviously some still bids
are
um it could be suggested quite
complicated
um how much of their time is taken we we
do this um
type of uh review for planning offices
and i'm just wondering
if there was anything that could um
confirm that
please okay well i'll pass that on to
christine thurlow in a minute because
she heads up the team i don't know if
she's got any idea
um that what sort of proportion of time
is actually spent on
what i think you're referring to is
silly inquiries isn't it
because when somebody shows an interest
in the possible submission of a seal bid
there's particularly
applies to community bids um the
the first point of contact if you like
um is the seal team to make an inquiry
and christine and her team give all
sorts of advice
on what might be able to be funded what
percentage
might be awarded what the maximum might
be
and any other sources of funding we
still run a community grants program
and there are other sources of funding
out there we always look for
collaborative bids
as as i'm sure you're aware um in the
last review we restricted community bids
to
75 and 75 000 pounds
so putting together a collaborative bid
is really really important
for community groups but if they're i
mean i'm not aware
of a percentage of christine's time or
her team's time that's spent on inquiry
but christine can you can you help
uh thank you uh i don't have any precise
figures about that
all i would say is that we do encourage
people to
have conversations with us at the
earliest possible stage
if we don't do that what we end up with
is
a lot of sill bids which either don't
meet
the requirements of the scheme and so
therefore we've got decisions
uh that we we end up having to
resist the project or uh or amend it
substantially the other reason why we
encourage people to come to us early on
is because we're trying to
produce a program of infrastructure
delivery
and i think with the sill expenditure
programs that we bring to cabinet there
is a list
of infrastructure projects which are now
um listed in section c
of the report no b of the report uh
which actually gives
members a flavor of of what is being
informally discussed and so they can see
uh which direction infrastructure
delivery is
is moving in and it also allows us to
to understand uh how much
uh investment is needed in order to
service
all of those projects if we want to
support them all
thank you uh thank you
thank you and if i may madam madam
chairman
um i think that clarifies the position
that
it obviously saves time in the long run
with the officers if it is done that way
and thank you for the clarification
christine thank you thank you councillor
mabry councillor mccraw
actually just to confirm that could
christine confirm that somewhat akin to
a pre-application advice designed
effectively to
to make the process more efficient and
not waste time
christine thurlow is that correct
that is correct yes thank you
thank you are there any further
questions
councilman crawl you've still got your
hand up have you a further question
i do not okay thank you
are there any further questions if not
we can move to debate
oh councillor hinton is that a question
or are you opening the debate
i would like to start on the debate i
think otherwise we'll be going
please proceed yes please proceed you
can open the debate
um yes just one one uh one point that i
would like to make quite strongly and
that is that uh
so as self funds are outside of the
budget
the fact that the cabinet decides on the
merits of
bids um is not
particularly in line with the
constitution bearing in mind that their
limit is 150 000 pounds
within the budget but sell is outside of
the budget
and anything that's outside of the
budget should be decided by full council
and yet full council doesn't get a
chance to have a sniffing at any of
these things
and i think it's important that council
is involved
more in these sorts of decisions uh
otherwise
we have to ask ourselves why do we
bother with councillors at all why don't
we just elect
10 people to cabinet and forget about
the rest
um so we've got to we've got to i think
we've got to
say that cross-border silver funding
whereas
clive has has quite uh i think
appropriately said it's going to be
about sort of 20 million for a project
these are going to be big projects
they're going to be big projects uh are
going to be well outside cabinet's
spending limit
and um should be decided by full council
and then everybody is involved and can
have their say and and decide on
the merits of it
well can i just say i i don't know if
council hinton misunderstood that
um i was talking about the possible
quantum
of um the the amount that
ipswich might require um i wasn't
talking about the size of our
contribution
um i did mention that you know they
they sort of may in initial talks have
said well you know perhaps it should be
a quarter a fifth or whatever
which would be several million pounds
but the whole point of what we're saying
today
is that it's not going to work like that
it's going to be based on evidence and
they're going to have to actually show
us the scheme
so it's highly unlikely that it would be
a
a significant amount of money um in the
millions
there is another can i can i respond to
another part of that question because
council hints and was good enough
to give me advanced warning
of of what he was going to say and i did
take the opportunity of getting a little
bit of advice
from emily ewell just around
whether a large sill award if there were
to be one
proposed would still fall within
an executive decision to be made by
cabinet
it may be better if emily
responds if she's available responds
just to explain
the the decision for cabinet and
to explain why it wouldn't fall to be
a council decision before she does that
though
i you know i've i've got a bit of
sympathy with
um with what council hinton is saying
and i see absolutely no reason
why um cabinet shouldn't be um given
good advance warning even debate um
a large um contribution if one were to
be asked for
but we we haven't been asked for one yet
thank you i'll invite our monitoring
officer emily your to
add to the conversation here
thank you chair um yes on the point of
whether a seal decision
falls to the cabinet or to the council
the local authority's function and
responsibilities england regulations
2000
actually set out the legal framework for
decisions that
cannot be taken by the council's
executive i.e the cabinet
and therefore mean that those decisions
are
reserved to the full council sill
decisions
are not reserved to the full council and
they are not listed as a local choice
function
where the council has discretion about
who the decision maker is
so therefore they are executive
functions and they fall to the cabinet
to be made
setting the framework is a council
function hence why the report is here
this evening
in terms of financial limits there is no
limit to the decision that the cabinet
can take uh councillor hinton is right
when he
has talked about the um decisions must
be
consistent with the council's approved
budget but of course with sill
you cannot budget um explicitly for seal
because it is dependent on applications
coming forward and the decisions around
the sill
amounts that need to be levied against
each of those planning decisions
and chair i hope that it explains the
separation of those functions but i'm
happy to provide any further clarity as
required
thank you and chairman if i could come
back on that i think the monitoring
officer has very clearly
demonstrated why it should be a cabinet
decision another
sorry a council decision and not a
cabinet decision
because you can't budget for it and
therefore it should be a cabinet
decision rather than
sorry a council decision rather than a
cabinet decision
um and it should involve lots of people
if we were on a 106 regime
it would be done by the planning
committee not by cabinet
and the 150 000 is within the budget
whereas we're talking here about
considerably more than that
um i think i'm right can i just come
back on that chairman yes please do
yeah i think i'm right in saying that if
it was a if it was a 106 it would only
be the decision on the 106 that would be
made either by
planning committee or under delegated
powers you wouldn't see it again after
that
so with sill there's a framework in
place
and there is an automatic levy um
what happens with the money when it's
received like a 106
members would not normally be involved
in that
if you cast your mind back councillor
hinton to pre-seal days
um the involvement of councillors was in
in
was was in the the setting of the
106 under the provisions of uh
an approval um and once we did that
we had no further part in that
expenditure taking place
so i think no but that's madam chairman
mr hinton i've
already give you're officially only
allowed to speak once
and i've allowed you to speak twice um
unless there's anything more to
add to it counselor arthi i think we'll
move on now
are you happy to do that counselor arthi
i thank you
yes i think we'll move the debate on a
bit now
um councillor hinton councillor mayberry
uh thank you very much madam chairman um
i
do actually concur with councillor
councillor hinton
um because this is what i think is
worrying me when i ask the
pertinent questions about um percentage
for
across any cross border beats
it actually states and i can't bring it
up and i'm sorry it's less than number
26 i know that
in the in the sill framework that um
sport and recreation can be
200 000 which
is a relatively small amount if you look
at the cost of recreation however
again it is above the um council
budget limit that a cabinet can decide
on
and i have heard what emily you all of
the monitoring officer
has said but this does leave me
with great concern that we could
be giving all the decisions to the
cabinet
over sill and i don't actually think
it's fair
uh councillor arthy has spoken about
s106
now he he was not around with chilton
woods when that
was first discussed the s106 money and i
can assure you
if the parish had not intervened there
with s106
and that we would never have got any
funding for
the community hall or community building
so i am really really worried about
this um and i must say
i am erring on to not actually
voting for this because i am really
worried
about the amount of money that could
possibly
be given away it may well be that they
are good causes
by the coven by the cabinet on things
that
not every member has had been able to
comment on
or is in agreement with thank you i
think that's my last and
that my one and only comment that i'm
allowed but i don't think
chairman can i respond to that please do
well only that um there's um something
about what councillor mayberry has said
that
implies um something that that didn't
actually happen
the the parish council didn't intervene
in order to
secure a 106. the decision
on the conditions and the 106 um
that was um agreed
that was a decision of baby district
council chilton parish council are not
the planning authority
baby district council are and that
condition was attached by virtue
of the consent that was granted for the
outline by baba district council
yes but are we veering off the point
here originally
given to the parish council can i just
ask you to keep to the
point of um the debates that we're meant
to be discussing here today please
um rather than getting on to individual
cases
aristo must scrawl have you got a
something you'd like to contribute to
the
debate that's a a new variation on my
name
i'm sorry my apologies alistair mayer
i must admit that's a new one on me and
i've heard them all
that's not a problem i'm thinking we we
may be getting dragged down into
somewhat hypothetical discussions here
um and they're intensely uh hypothetical
we have not received such a bid in the
past
and i have a great deal of confidence in
the sill team's work
and and the infrastructure delivery plan
and the rest of the work that has been
done because we've looked at it so often
a couple of points that come to my mind
here a one that is not our
money it is ring fenced infrastructure
funds it does not form part of the
budget
and there is a thought that crosses my
mind that if
the decision made on such a hypothetical
case were
to be a cabinet decision i would have
thought it would have been subject
to calling under the call-in procedures
contained
in the constitution in which case there
would be a perfect opportunity at that
point
for a call-in process to take place um
where where there were such concerns
obviously as in all call-ins
specific to the individual circumstances
now it might be that we need the
monitoring officer to confirm
that these decisions are subject to call
in but as an executive decision
i can't see how they are not they are
subject to a decision
notice therefore i would believe they
must be
thank you council macro um the monster
officer is going
to make a comment here
thank you chair um yes i would like to
confirm uh the comments made by
councillor mccall
these decisions made by cabinet are
subject to the call-in rules
um if i may i wouldn't normally step in
during the debating um section but i did
just want to
um add some clarity to some of the
comments that
have been made and firstly in respect of
these decisions being an executive
function
um whilst we operate a cabinet model
of governance we are bound by the 2000
regulations that i quoted earlier
which set out the functions that must be
um
assigned to the executive cabinet and
the functions that must be reserved to
council
we cannot alter that the council does
not have the power to
supersede that legislation therefore the
legislation says
that seal decisions are an executive
function and therefore the cabinet must
make it it cannot be referred
by um this council to itself or decision
making
and the second point chair is just
around the um
financial limit that councillors are
mentioning
i i think there may be some confusion
with the key decision
threshold cabinet is not limited
um as to the value of decisions it can
make
however we do have a key decision
threshold of 150 000 pounds
and that threshold requires that the
decision is published for
28 days on the forthcoming decisions
list before the cabinet
can take the decision it doesn't prevent
the cabinet from taking that decision
it just requires that the decision is
publicly advertised
in advance thank you chair thank you
my point though chair and i think it's
an important one is that members if
members
were ever to have such concerns over a
large sill
bid they would have the calling
procedure to fall back upon
there is a there is therefore a
system in place for council to have some
oversight in the matter thank you
councillor holt thank you
i think emily may well have answered my
question which was really going to be
if cabinet was so decided to refer
an application to full council
for debate could they do so but from
what emily just said
the full council could possibly debate
it prior to a cabinet decision but it
still
ultimately would be a cabinet decision
is that right emily could we refer it to
council
for a debate and it came back to cabinet
for a decision
after that debate
through you chair that's exactly right
councillor holt um the cabinet could
refer for debate
only and then the decision is um still
within the hands of the cabinet
thank you thank you for that
clarification
are there any more um people who want to
join the debate
any more counselors wishing to speak
is there anything else you'd like to say
counselor arthy
no chairman i i think um councillor
mccraw and councillor holt have really
answered
asked the questions that i i was
preparing to answer
um so i mean i don't think that anybody
ought to be
um afraid i think there is i mean there
are two issues really one
one is um the government governance
model
and that's a debate for another day um
if people don't agree
with the cabinet um model of governance
um
that's you know something that could be
changed in the future
i think that where councillor hinton is
coming from
is that it seems um that there are
a lot of important decisions that are
reserved for cabinets i don't think
necessarily this is
one um that should worry members
particularly
um you know it's it's the self framework
that we've
had for the last three years it's
changing it to adapt to
um to likely proposals coming forward
the the same decision-making criteria
will exist as as do at present um
with the the additional caveat if you
like that cross-boundary issues
will not be delegated if they fall below
the 10 000
threshold all cross-boundary issues will
come to cabinet
um and council holds and councillor
mccraw have
um have outlined what can happen if
large
applications come forward and and
cabinet can if they want
um refer to council um or to overview
and scrutiny committee
the last thing that i would add is that
every year overview and scrutiny
um look at not only um the changes to
the seal framework
but the performance of seal generally
and i think
i don't know if you can invite
councillor mccraw to speak again
but i think that overview and scrutiny
have on all occasions thus far
been particularly pleased with the way
that still has worked for us
council macro did you want to make any
statement here
only only to agree only to agree with
councillor arthur's statement we've
been impressed with the work of the sill
framework
uh members group
we've been impressed with the work uh
which sill has
undertaken i think one of the appendices
contains
a careful tracking of every single sill
bid
in many instances sil money has actually
been returned
to the fund something i note i also note
that we have quite a large amount of
sill money
within fund and i know council arthi has
become concerned about that at some
point
this is a time where people really need
to be thinking about getting their bids
together
no effectively the greater great
advantage that has been
obvious is that the cell framework has
developed that it has become
it's reactive and proactive this is an
example of being proactive
not reactive but we know that these
larger bids
will come forward because that is the
way that the world is moving
thank you council mccraw okay could i
finally then if we have finished um
could i just thank the members of the
panel for their contributions
um it's a panel that works very very
well
so we'd like to carry on with that
that's part of one of the
recommendations
and also to thank christine and her team
um
christine set up a new team when we um
implemented sil
and if any of you get involved in any um
community bids in your ward you will
know how
incredibly helpful the sil team are from
initial first inquiry all the way
through
so if any of you have in your wards
a potential infrastructure project
a community infrastructure project
please have a have a word with with
christine have a word with joe have a
word with the team
and they will they they offer incredible
help they really do they're fantastic so
thank you very much to the team as well
thanks thank you councillor arthy so i
think we're now ready to
move to the vote um councillor arthi
earlier in his presentation
um stated the recommendations
for us to vote on very clearly and
now you've heard the debate so i think
we're now ready to go to the vote
so i'll now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office
to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair councillors can you open
the vote in the modern.gov app by
clicking the plus sign in the top right
hand of the agenda screen
and selecting attendance and voting the
voting tab for this agenda item will
show in blue and please click on that
blue line to open the vote
thank you
councillor beer um are you able to vote
or would you like to take to make your
vote verbally
[Music]
councillor beer are you able to vote
[Music]
uh oh it's gone would you like
would you like to make it verbally yes
uh i i support the recommendations
okay thank you i got to the photo and
when you spoke to me i pressed the mark
and that took the whole lot off the
screen
okay thank you
yeah thank you chair that's 25
4 3 against and one abstention thank you
thank you
so that is carried
we'll move on now to item 10
paper bc 2031
response to the consultation on the
future of the new
homes bonus i would like to invite
council award
to introduce paper bc 2031
and to move the recommendations in the
report council award
thank you chair i'm pleased to introduce
report bc 2031 the response to the
consultation on the future of new homes
bonus
the long-awaited consultation on the
replacement for new homes bonus was
finally published by the ministry of
housing communities and local government
on the 10th of february with an
eight-week consultation window
the monitoring officer has concluded
that this consultation is of sufficient
significance for it to be referred to
full council for a response
as consultation responses are normally
delegated to the relevant assistant
director under the council's
constitution
due to the short timescale offered by
mhclg
it was not possible for officers to
prepare a draft response to be
considered at our meeting today
so it is proposed that a joint
cross-party working group is established
to agree a response with the assistant
director for corporate resources for
submission by the deadline of 7th of
april
the proposed membership of the group is
set out in paragraph 4.6 of the report
i should also remind you i set out and
report at paragraph 4.7
that all counsellors are entitled to
make their own personal response to the
consultation
if they so wish i would like to propose
the recommendations are set out in three
one and three two
and would ask for a seconder and i'm
happy to take any questions
thank you john osborne are you offering
to
second this proposal i am thank you
madam chairman
thank you thank you
so we'll now move to questions have you
got some questions
councillor lindsay have you got a
question
counselor lindsay yes i have thank you
chair
um just on the um
the the the method of consultation
um uh 4.6
um the membership of the working group
um you've got two cabinet members
and then two councillors
from the independent green liberal
democrat or labour group
um independent
and liberal democrat groups are not in
the opposition there on the cabinet
so you could end up with four cabinet
members there
if you look at the way the mid-south
have done it
you've got two cabinet members and two
people from the opposition so i'd submit
only green and labour in the opposition
in this council and the so the
councillors should be selected from that
group thank you
councillor hinton did you have a comment
as well
on that same uh paragraph actually 4.6
and that is it seems a bit strange that
within babel we're talking i'm not
really concerned about what midsuffer
get up to
but within baber we're talking about the
cabinet member for finance
yes we're talking about new homes bonus
which is money based
cabinet member for housing well the
cabinet member for housing is
responsible for all
council housing not for open market
housing so the best person to be put
into that position would be the cabinet
member for planning
which would be a much more appropriate
position to put in the
person to have on that particular make
up as far as the remaining two
councillors are concerned
that would have to be up to the uh the
leaders to sort out
seem to have moved into debate but uh
nevertheless
uh council mccraw did you
have a question i suspect i'd best leave
it for debate
okay thank you
are there any questions that um
madam chairman if i could just come back
on that
question at this stage
too much of a restriction when it came
to the debate in that why isn't it the
cabinet member for planning rather than
the cabinet member for housing
okay council award would you like to
answer that question please
we just decided that it would be the
cabinet member for housing uh it could
equally be the cabinet member for
planning but
um uh i can take that offline with those
two cabinet members concerned and um
and discuss that with them but um it's
it's not really um something that i can
decide on at this stage uh immediately
here
here and now fine
oh yes you have another question yes
counselor um
i understood that this was in actual
fact going to be a council
decision not a leader decision so why
can't we make that decision now
amendment you've all gone very quiet we
can
um make an amendment and um if you'd
like to propose that as an amendment
we can do that and then um
and then we can debate the amendment i
would certainly like to propose that as
an amendment then
okay council award would you accept that
amendment
yes oh sorry councillor hinton i need to
ask you do you have a second
is there a second of four um your
amendment
is that councillor plum would you like
to second that
i will second that amendment fine
council award
would you like to accept that amendment
yes fine in that case we'll
um ask questions to the amendment
no debate
sorry check could could we have been
i'm sorry i'm sorry councillor lindsay
i i'm not sure what the amendment is
could we could we have the amendment
read out yes
um our monitoring officer is just going
to come in here
thank you chair
for the avoidance of doubt um councillor
hinton seconded by councillor plum have
proposed that in 4.6
the cabinet member for planning is a
member of the
joint council cross-party working group
rather than the cabinet member for
housing
the proposal of the report council award
has accepted that amendment
um so that now becomes the substantive
motion
so essentially the recommendation stays
the same chair
but the membership is now the cabinet
member for finance
the cabinet member for planning and then
two other members
to be agreed by the leaders of the uh
relevant political groups listed in 4.6
thank you chair thank you emily
council mccraw did you want to just
a point that that can surely only be the
case for the baber
membership of the working group it
cannot be for mid-suffering
that would be correct thank you
counselor rc um yeah i'm just thinking i
mean if an amendment
is put forward um on those lines is
there any particular reason
why um we can't we can't select all four
members
we could have proposals come forward
couldn't we from
um the greens liberal democrats and
labor um for two people
so we could end up actually knowing who
all four are
otherwise we're going to leave the other
two members of that group to i don't
know what what some sort of
um smoky room discussion and then to
drop out i'm not quite sure
um i don't know if if um councillor
lindsay is
leader of the green group has got
somebody in mind
um i don't know if democrats or labour
have
but i mean if you have why don't you
just say so and we'll sort it all out
and we've got a group
councillor lindsay uh
yes thank you for that um councillor
harvey we do have someone in mind
councillor jane gould
right so
and council award anything any comments
you wanted to make here
happy to accept councillor gould on that
working group yeah
fine councillor holt
yes just just a point um it's all very
well mentioned
in 4.6 that two councillors from
independent green and liberal democrat
and labor but what about conservatives
it seems rather um discriminative to
exclude the conservative group from
potentially having
a second councillor mentioned on there i
just think it's unfair that
conservatives aren't going to include
the rest it should include all
but the cabinet member for finance is
already
on the group this is a bucket breakdown
this isn't about the breakdown of it
all i'm saying is for fairness it should
be all the groups
whether the conservatives wanted to add
someone or put someone forward as
another matter
but it should include all the remaining
groups
that would be my position i just want to
make that clear i think it's unfair not
to include everyone
okay you've stated your position thank
you council halt
um counselor
beer councillor beer would you like to
say something please to this um
thank you madam chairman yes i i support
what um council halters just said
i think that if we're going to do this
at the 11th hour
we're putting all names in the hat um
the leader of the council is being
forced in a position
to accept names uh i think we should all
be able to vote on this separately and i
think
um that the four names uh should be put
in the hat
um of whatever political parties they
come from
thank you sorry i don't have a problem
with counselor
um the uh counselor
osbourne or councillor arffy
thank you council beer council davis
councillor derek davis thank you yeah
sorry um no i agree with with um pretty
much
both of what's just been said quite
frankly it should be the best person for
the job
um i'm i'm totally supportive of cancer
i know she would um she would do an
excellent job
and and if there are others that would
like to be considered
and and the leader because you know
let's let's not forget
he he is the leader um you know
are there but surely it's the best
person for the job
irrespective of the parties
council ward is there anything you'd
like to add um
right well let's let's try and get this
sorted out now as everyone
um really wants to and i think that's a
good idea so we have the cabinet member
for finance
proposed uh here the cabinet member for
planning
council of gould and for the fourth
member i would still like to propose
councillor
john osborne so that for me is
the uh the four-member working group
that i would like to see
thank you we now have the four members
on the uh panel laid before us
would anyone like to comment on that
composition
sure is that council allison mccraw
it is indeed right would you like to
speak i think i have
something of a solution because when
councillor lindsay raised this question
it came to my mind that the situation
that mid-suffolk and ourselves are
different
uh mid-suffolk has a virtually split um
conservative opposition uh alignment and
equality of representation according to
something of the number of seats is
something we've used in all our
committees
so i would suggest for baber that two
conservatives made up for whatever
position they may come from
as council award has suggested there's
no reason why
you couldn't have three cabinet members
an independent
or a liberal democrat all late well i
think it would be sensible to have an
independent there
this happens to be councillor rc and the
green
and i'd fully support that effectively
two conservatives one independent and
one green
vastly is a vastly superior way of
reflecting the makeup of this council
and that's the basis on which i think we
should proceed
has anyone else got any comment that
they'd like to add to that
preferably from someone who hasn't
spoken to date
sue carpendale councillor carpendale
thank you chair i find myself in
agreement with councillor holt and with
councillor mccraw
it seems a very sensible solution i'm
not terribly happy with making decisions
on the hoof
but i do think this will work
thank you for that counselor arthur your
hand is
still up um did you want to make a
comment
uh not i did but not anymore thank you
councillor gold
thank you yes um i think i am aware that
it's rather decision made on the hoof
um um i had had a conversation with
councillor lindsay this afternoon before
council and supported up
i wouldn't want you thinking that i was
a surprise
sorry mr leader council award
but i would i would um enjoy doing the
job
so thank you very much for your support
of me and we'll see where it leads
thank you madam chair thank you
well um we seem to be coming to some
conclusion here
even though it wasn't the original
intention of this meeting
um well councillor osborne councillor
john osborne would you like to speak
thank you madam chairman as my name has
been mentioned several times i feel
perhaps i better should come in
yet now i'm more than happy to sit on
this group and it has been alluded to
that i'm responsible for social housing
but actually
the order of all the parts of housing
comes into my remit in one way or
another
that's part of my responsibility so i
would very much like to sit on this
group i do have a full understanding of
new homes bonus
and housing so i'm more than happy to um
sit on this group as suggested by our
leader council award
thank you madam chairman thank you
councillor beer your hand is still up
did you want to say something
oh it shouldn't be i'll put it down
sorry thank you that's
okay thank you no problem thank you
so we seem to have come to a conclusion
here we seem to have the full makeup of
the
um the the panel
so um i think we can vote on that
now um we the debate seems to have
completed
so i think we
is i our monitoring officer has already
told us what we will be
voting for if everyone's clear on that
we now seem to have the full makeup of
the group so i will now ask the
corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic
vote thank you chair yeah we have
um amended those recommendations so that
4.6
is as amended so thank you so counselors
if you could open the vote in the
modern.gov app by clicking the plus sign
in the top right hand agenda screen and
selecting attendance and voting
that vote will now show in blue and
please click on the blue line to open
the vote
thank you
hey again bye
councillor newman are you a people to
vote would you like to
do it manually
actually we have now received it thank
you
chair that is 28 4 and 1 abstention
thank you
thank you so that vote is carried
thank you so now we'll move on to item
11
bc 2032
pay policy statement 2021 to 22
and the gender pay gap i would like to
invite council award
to introduce paper bc 2032
and to move the recommendations in the
report
council award thank you chair i'm
pleased to introduce report bc 2032
the pay policy statement 2021-22 gender
pay gap report
we are required by the 2011 localism act
to prepare and publish a pay policy
statement that is approved by council
and by the 2010 equality act to report
on our gender
pay gap the latter does not have to be
approved by council
as the two councils have a single
organizational structure with harmonized
pay
grades terms and conditions of service a
single pay policy statement is produced
which covers both councils
last year the statement was contained
within the budget report in february
2020
but due to the recent changes to the
senior leadership team announced by the
chief executive last week
it was not possible to reflect these
changes and meet the timetable for the
february council meeting
and hence it is being presented to
council today
paragraph 3.3 of the report sets out the
key information that is contained within
the statement
at appendix a and paragraph 3.4
highlights the changes made compared to
the statement for the current year
the gender pay gap report is normally
published by 31st of march each year
but due to the impact of covid this has
been extended to the 31st of october
so the report is not yet available as we
are two sovereign councils the gender
pay gap report has to be published for
each council
but the combined data is more relevant
due to our workforce being fully
integrated
some of you may have spotted that within
the risk section of the report the first
and third risks are repeated
this is an error and it should only have
been in there once
i would like to propose the
recommendations are set out in 2.1 and
2.2
and would ask for a seconder i would be
happy to answer any questions that you
have
and with me are suzanne hughes our head
of hr and organizational development
who many of you will not have met before
and catherine steele the assistant
director to assist me with this with
this
thank you thank you thank you counselor
arty are you
proposing a second day thank you
thank you so have we got any questions
we'll now move to questions
you have any questions on this report
if there are no questions you can move
to debate
does anyone like to open the debate
you're allowed to speak for three
minutes and speak
once
so if there's no one wishing to
open the debate
we can move straight to the vote
and just to
[Music]
remind councillors what the
recommendations are
i'll read those recommendations out
so the recommendation 2-1 that the
proposed pay policy statement
for 2001 to 22
are set out in section b be approved
2.2 that publication
of the council's gender pay gap as of
31st
march 2020 be noted
so as there are no questions and no
no one wish to open a debate we'll move
straight
to the vote i'll now ask the corporate
manager governance and civic office
to conduct the chronic vote thank you
chair councillors the vote is now
open please click on the plus sign in
the top right hand
agenda screen and select attendance and
voting that vote will now show in blue
please click on the blue line to open
the vote thank you
councillors you will also need to scroll
down for this vote thank you
okay
councillor beer are you able to vote or
would you like to to give your vote
verbally
cancer beer are you able to i can you
hear me
okay um
councillor beer are you able to um vote
okay okay we will um move on without
counsellor beer's vote thank you
chair that is unanimous thank you
so that was a unanimous vote so it's
carried thank you
item 12 bc 2033
appointment of the independent
remuneration panel
i would like to invite the corporate
manager for governance and civic office
to introduce paper bc 2033
thank you chair the current panel that
was appointed in 2016 has now reached
the end of their term
under the local authorities members
allowances england regulations 2003
the council is required to establish and
maintain a panel known as the
independent remuneration panel
to make recommendations amendments of
the members allowances scheme a
recruitment exercise has been undertaken
candidates were selected from applicants
who had made a formal application
and underwent a competitive interview
council is therefore asked to approve
the formal appointment of the
recommended panel members for four years
with an option to extend this for
another four years
and also to confirm the fee payable for
each review
and also the payment of reasonable
expenses i'm happy to take any questions
share thank you
thank you could i have a proposal please
our council award thank you be happy to
propose
thank you and um just a quick comment i
know
we have five candidates here um and you
you'll read their
um uh their details they're all five
excellent candidates
i think it will make an excellent panel
thank you
um could i have a seconder i'm i'm happy
to second
and me thank you
councillor davis i'll go for councillor
davis thank you spoke first
thank you so um we'll now move to
questions
counselors may ask as many questions as
they wish however they must be relevant
to the subject under discussion
and must be a question counselor hinton
have you got a question yes quick
question uh
nowhere within the sort of resumes that
have been put forward
does it give any strong indications as
to where these
applicants reside
and as such means that we don't really
know what
might be considered reasonable expenses
um
in the uh in the recommendations so
could we know where they actually live
um chair just just to clarify we're not
able to put obviously the the people's
addresses we have um
three members that live with in the
district and two that are outside
their reasonable expenses would we're
hoping to conduct most of the meetings
virtually and
all of the interviews so it the the
expenses
would be very minimal thank you thank
you
councillor lindsay
thank you chair um yeah i just um
wondered how often do
does this panel we expecting them to do
uh a review
is it just once in the four years that
they're appointed or every year or
every six months or what
chair a lot of it would depend on the
circumstances we would expect it to be
one or two possibly reviews unless there
were any um
to governance arrangements or any other
arrangements which
could see councillors duties be expanded
or
retracted even so it would literally
depend on the circumstances within those
four years but
looking at it sensibly probably one or
two at the most
okay thank you i'll have an observation
but i'll
come back to that when it goes to debate
thank you okay thank you
councillor rc
yeah i think can i can i save mine for
debate i think it's probably more of a
debate than a
question yeah councilman easy have you
got a
i do madam chairman um how many
four-year terms have they done
um chair there they have not done any so
far they
are a completely new panel from the
panel that was there previously
okay thank you
has anyone else got any questions
so if there are no more questions um we
can move to the debate
um councils will only be allowed to
speak once
for three minutes and this will be timed
counselor arthi i think you wanted to
you were saving your um question for the
debate
yeah i mean it's just to make a point
really i mean members will note at
paragraph
7.1
the council appoints the panel
and um should have regard to the views
of the panel when they're expressed
i just kind of hope that happens because
i've seen lots of these take place
i've been on the council for 30 years
now and what tends to happen
is that the responsibilities the time
commitments
comparisons with other authorities
they're all provided to the panel
and the panel come up with um what they
think
is a fair remuneration it then goes to
council and we slash it
so we're always behind what the panel
recommends so you kind of think what's
the point of having a panel because
whatever they recommend we're
we're not going to agree it um i think
mid suffolk did last time
so we've got the strange situation where
our leader is
not remunerated as well as mid-suffolk's
leader for the responsibilities that he
takes on
and i i will say now that i don't think
anybody
should underestimate the amount of time
and commitment that john ward gives to
his role as leader
i know that a lot of the things that we
do aren't popular with
everybody in the district and there are
people who disagree with some
things that would say well he shouldn't
be there at all type of thing
but john's commitment to the council um
and the amount of time that he puts in
as leader i mean i'm
deputy leader um so i i get to know
about
um the things that john has to do he's
got the finance portfolio as well
and if i'm really honest i i think it's
it's
um it's almost an insult
um the amount that we remunerate a
leader
it may well be that we have the
government's model argument in a year or
two's time
and we may not have a a cabinet and and
a leader
but while we do i think people who take
on these
additional responsibilities and the time
commitment that goes with them
i really don't feel are properly
remunerated for the extra work that they
do
thank you thank you councillor arthur
councillor lindsay
yes thank you again um so
my my thoughts on this is that i mean
i'm not sure
going back when in in the past
remuneration
panels like this have made their
recommendations
but the timing is key because i feel as
a matter of principle that
it that we should have recommendations
before the end of our terms as
councillors
and then we vote as councillors for the
new council the remuneration of the new
council
that comes after the elections
rather than voting for our basically our
own allowances
so i think it's really important to to
that we get recommendations
yes they should be listened to right
council ralph is right
but the timing of it is so important we
we need
recommendations for the next regime the
next set of councillors
so that so that if and if we are
intending to stay on and hope to get
re-elected
we can face the electorate and explain
why
we you know and they can make judgment
why we if we want to increase the
allowances why
we need to do so um but i think
if we get a recommendation immediately
after everyone's re-elected
um or not when there's a new council and
the new council's vote on it
they're just it's like um you know
you're voting for your own your own
remuneration
and it's immediately after the election
so the electorate immediately suspect a
rat
and i just think it makes us look bad so
timing is key is what i'd say thank you
thank you councillor lindsay
councillor hinton
thank you madam chairman well to a
certain extent i agree with what
councilor lindsay said
but i would also say that uh uh
timing is is the essence from the point
of view that it can be used politicized
uh and used against sitting councillors
by the electorate
so it's a it's a difficult one to get
right
if you if you vote for renumeration
increases or whatever just before an
election the electorate can turn around
saying oh i see
they're voting for more money for
themselves if they get re-elected so
we'll make sure they don't get
re-elected
so it's a it's a it's a double-edged
weapon
and uh it's something that is very
difficult to get right and i think what
we've got
to do is to make sure that we uh
promote the fact that the
renumerations board is independent
uh and then take take it from there
thank you councillor hinton councillor
davis
yeah thank you and um very similar
thoughts to both
uh council hinton and council lindsay
but what i would say
is i think it's really really important
that all
councillors engage in the process
um yeah we've been through this before
what some of us sorry
some of us have been through this before
um i voted against the recommendations
last time
because i thought our increases were
disproportionate to
the increases the council officers were
getting hopefully this time round
because
we will be um keeping up if you like
and there won't be such a huge gap um
and i'm
certainly not preempting what the
independent members would do
but uh you know it's really important
that all council members
give the independent members when
they're doing their
research all the information they can
and i think it's important
and i think this is where the timing
would be less critical
is that we are not making huge
jumps in uh in in our allowances
uh but i would also agree with council
rafi that yeah
we were um you know we we got left
behind
um in terms of the leader and some of
the other allowances
but that's i think is because we we
there'd been a failure
if you like in them in what what had
happened beforehand
so yes it's important that the
the independent members get all the
information they can
and they come up with a very very um
agreeable solution and we don't smash it
we don't knock it down because
it's acceptable to all of us are you
know
on all groups on all sides of it so that
that's why i think it's important that
this independent panel
get all the support that we as
councillors can give them
thank you thank you councillor davis
councillor mabry
thank you chairman um yes i've i've been
listening
to this i do a lot of listening um
and reflecting and i would agree with um
quite a bit of what um councillor hinton
and councillor
lindsay have said however i do think
that there is a little bit of
strange commenting from certain members
because i will remember when
the cabinet was first formed some
who are now in the cabinet who were in
the opposition
at that time totally voted against any
allowance for cabinet members
so i do find this a bit double-edged
and it is really interesting to hear
these people actually say oh you must
make sure that the remuneration
panel will get all the information um
and i just find it quite ironic
that they would be saying things like
that and oh
there's lots of hands coming up so i
expect i will be getting some comments
but i will reiterate again and this is
recorded
that many of those who are commenting
that we must listen to the remuneration
panel etc etc
were those who were dead against giving
any allowance to the cabinet thank you
thank you councillor mabry
councillor ward
to be honest i'm not quite sure how
relevant uh that last statement was to
the the matter at hand
all we're debating today is whether we
want to appoint
these five members as our panel we're
not we're not talking about
um the possible recommendations they
might make at some point in the future
we're not talking about whether the the
allowances we have at the moment
are too low too high just about right or
whatever we're talking about appointing
a panel
and we should just focus on that are
these five people the ones we want
thank you council warden indeed you're
correct
councilman crawl um were you
going to talk about these individuals
on the independent remuneration panel
no just the principle of having a
remuneration panel
rather implies that we could take the
politics out of this
it's been referred to about timing
perhaps the matter of timing
and the politics of it could be taken
out of it by simply letting the
remuneration panel do their job
i've always felt and stated that we need
people to be able to be counsellors and
for that to be the case
reasonable expenses are required a
member's allowance is required
that's a basic principle i think that
should apply in all
forms of government so let them do their
job
uh appoint them and let them decide when
the best time to hold
their next uh set of meetings perhaps in
conversation with the monitoring officer
or the governance officers
i'm very happy to support this motion
and i think we should waste no further
time on it
thank you it doesn't look as if there's
anyone else that wants to join in the
debate now anyway
so in that case we'll move to the
recommendations
um i'll just read those out um
recommendation 3.1 that the following
persons be appointed to the council's
independent remuneration panel
amanda orchard sarah way monica collibio
john clough and sue putters
recommendation 3.2 that the irp
members each be paid 500 pounds
for each review carried out and being
reimbursed any expenses reasonably
incurred
in the performance of their duties 3.3
that the irp be appointed for a period
of four years
with the option to extend this for
another period
of four years if required
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office
to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair um councillors the vote
is now open
please go to the attendance and voting
button and press
the the line will shine show in blue and
please click on the blue line to open
the boat
thank you
councillor cresswell are you able to do
the vote um or would you like to place
it verbally
okay we have now got cancer cresswells
cancer beer are you still in the meeting
okay we will go ahead anyway
chair the vote is 26 4 and 1 abstention
thank you thank you so that vote is
carried
item 13 on our agenda counselor
appointments
i refer you to paper bc 2034 in the
tabled papers
i would like to invite the monitoring
officer to introduce paperbc
2034. thank you
[Applause]
thank you chair following the
resignation of councillor granger howard
it is necessary for us to recalculate
the allocation of seats of committee
seats to political groups
to reflect the vacant seat on the
council
after reviewing those calculations the
only
group that's affected is the
conservative group and the seat to be
lost is on the overview and scrutiny
committee
therefore the council needs to confirm
the new allocations as detailed in
appendix a
and note the change of membership and i
would ask the leader of the conservative
group council award to just confirm the
name of the councillor
who will be stepping down from that
committee thank you chair
thank you emily uh councillor dawson
will be stepping down from the european
scrutiny committee
thank you council ward could i have a
proposer
i'm happy to propose it cancer dawson
thank you councillor dawson and the
seconder please
yeah i will dave bust me thank you
councillor busby um are there any
questions on this
no questions so if there are no
questions we'll now move straight to the
electronic vote
can i ask the corporate manager governor
governance and civic office
to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair the vote is now open if
councillors would like to place their
vote
thank you
chair that is 26 4 and one abstention
thank you
thank you so that vote is carried thank
you
so we're now coming towards the end of
our meeting this evening
our next meeting is may which will be
our annual meeting but
prior to that i would just like to say
that um
this is probably my last full meeting
that i'll be taking so i just wanted to
take the opportunity
um today of thanking everyone
for their support particularly the
officers but also
fellow councillors i've
very much enjoyed my time i will speak
further
at the annual meeting in may i'm sure
you won't be able to stop me
and i just wanted to say thank you all
very much
for all your support through these
meetings that have been
very different from the normal way that
we
are used to having our meetings prior to
this time and in particular as i say the
support of the officers
who've had to handle a new way of
working which
um we've all been going through here
which has been
quite an interesting prospect for all of
us and i think we're practic
we're just about there with um getting
hold of
of how to handle it all now so thank you
all very much for your patience
and support councillor busby did you
want to say
something yeah i'd just like to say i
think you've been a star
well done oh oh that's
really kind thank you i agree oh thank
you
me three you end up crying well
thank you thank you i think catherine if
i could join those thanks as well but
just to say that
um a particular thanks i mean you've had
the most difficult year that any council
chairman could have had for chair and
council meetings
um some people may not realize that
every time we have a council meeting you
have to trot off to endeavor house
so that you've got all of the itun
support that you need to conduct the
meeting
and you have done a fantastic job so it
is a
big big thank you well done
thank you thank you for all your support
and patience
thank you thank you catherine
just to say no it's a pleasure and thank
you adrian for your support
as um my vice chairman
um i just want to mention that the date
of the next meeting
it which is the annual meeting is
tuesday 25th
of may and it will be at 5
30. so i now will close the meeting but
i would like you all to stay
present um after don't sign off yet
um as the monitoring officer would like
to make a statement
about future meetings so thank you all
very much
please stay on online
for now the meeting the public part of
the meeting
will now close thank you everybody
and have a good evening
you